first of all I want to shout out the
Theo von for guest of the year I just
wanted sure did just I told you one last
time
oh wait I love how you break the news we
had a lot of voters how many thousands
man I'm happening where could they both
be right on the damn computer is what I
heard it was a close the deal Vaughn I
think one by two percent over what
Dahlia I don't know it was that close it
was a neck-and-neck super close how
about the lis addressed last night a
couple things to talk about
daliyah dress like a in Miami Dolphin
like that what I like the way he dresses
he just had a turquoise and then he had
the orange Gatorade Jordans on yeah and
then he had and then he had that he
could just kept his hood on to annoy me
the whole time you are 37 you are not a
[ __ ] skater it's fun get it together
let's get tired last night at the candy
store it was very good found a robin's
shoes cuz he had him laced up those
things you could so like I said why is
shoes laces I was like what clown store
did you buy those shoes there's just
tons though well they're too floppy
they're laced up tight they're too long
they're tight yep
got some thick legs and very long feet
he wears a 27 it's 23 25 26 23 you know
Jamie bottom Easy's and then we're where
Jamie bought him easy yes but he has to
take him back to these to get a bigger
size I guess or smaller size it forget
but Romans like to know I'm not gonna
wear those Mike know this is what you
should do you need to just destroy him
like put them up put them on the trails
do like your thing that you do in normal
shoes yeah hilarious yes they're good
shoes like functional students are they
functional yeah I think they're the
ugliest things I know that's why I told
Rogen just like hiking them just [ __ ]
four guys me age they're so ugly
screaming hilarious yeah I know that's
why it's gonna be so fun yeah they look
like a spaceship to me yeah where are
the windows we agree they look a little
strange yeah they're definitely a
highbush and then Brendan thought it'd
be great we did two sets he and I at the
belly room fun sets fun that was a fun
little room yeah
Terrell Owens I was excited cuz Terrell
Owens was in the audience it was kind of
cool I was like oh you know me I'm like
hey that guy's really skin bug in my
head he was on your foot on this phone
text in the entire I mean I thought I
saw jaws behind the
not really nice there's not a realtor
because I want to hit him like dude you
left your phone yeah he was astonished
he wasn't watching anybody I didn't
watch why come yeah I don't know he was
toward the end but that didn't matter
um Brennen brings me up in the the last
show it's like 11 o'clock at night
Flutie but time you kill me yeah 11:30
and he he does his thing and he goes you
guys give it up for the best one of the
best comedians on the planet and Bryan
Callen and he has psoriasis and we'll
Brian show me like like like I don't
know it was like dad it was like dead
hair
yes Rises everybody's like everybody I
have a disease disease disease my mother
saw my back oh by the way I'm in Mexico
where I talked about this but I had like
kind of a rash which is attractive she
goes you know you could have the measles
check the inside of your cheek she's
[ __ ] oh my what she goes check the
inside of your cheek do you have do you
have our tea do you have white and red
mark I'm like no I don't she goes push a
glass I want you to take a glass and
push it against one of your that one of
the little like bumps on your skin does
it does it stay white or does it get
whiter does it stay red I'm not doing
yeah mom science I ain't doing any of
that [ __ ] okay if I have measles I hope
I [ __ ] die so I'm just right right
yeah and ruin says just from diet yeah
it is reliant roll that would die but
but when I got sick they say the doctor
came to my room I go after I she's good
of course of course because your your
immune system he goes down so now it's
yeah how about this morning
my Porsche might be a lemon y'all might
be 11 never had more problems in my life
it's a brand-new Porsche GTS handsome
lava orange and we're just gonna have to
stop because I have to be so bad I'll
tell this story on the show I'll wait
because I want to be here because I want
to calm down then why don't you once you
tell us how your morning started Brennan
got a busy day you know you got a busy
day now now let's out late last night
about 5:00 a.m. with the Sun yep now can
I can I just I just want to get some
context and I want to set you up
let me manicure the target you buy
yourself six months ago a brand new
lipstick orange lipstick waffle orange
well you can go [ __ ] yourself because
I've never seen lava lava or lipstick or
in lava it's it's it's a nail polish or
no it's a lot of fights it's a hot mags
and it's a rich manly rich orange it's a
rich older lady old horrified ones they
wear that on their on their nails my mom
does your older it's it's my mom's nail
polish and that's fine I don't have a
problem with that the other way it's a
GTS a beautiful car it's a brand-new car
it's a Porsche now Porsche there is no
substitute that used to be that's gonna
play say they say it's the best car on
planet earth so talk to people who are
real car enthusiasts now when you draw a
lot of runners when you drop coin on a
brand new GTS here's here's the here's
the minimum you're asking for the
minimum you're ask anybody I can get
from point A to point B obviously I want
some pickup Civic to do that right right
muscle you an orange sieve and that's
why when I see it that's why when I see
a Civic I go is it the car you know why
I got my voice because I a today because
it gets me from now it's not a Porsche
because why did I go down inside pores
because a Porsche you got a little more
than a 2 B obviously you're gonna get
from A to B then you get performance
then you get all the other stuff that
goes with it broke well that's all I
want to say broke my heart
why on the road today down the 405 going
about 90 standard now the 405 is a very
busy highway with lots of fast moving
steel
pretty much well I'm going down then
just this sign pops up bling bling bling
bling
it's like yellow sign flashing the [ __ ]
is that and goes power shutting down
that's problem spaceship is gonna say
that Tesla you know there's no
electricity in the Sun electric car oh
do you mean power right power it's a
power reduced so he goes from nine eat
about thirty you in the lobby plane far
left when I'm like oh it probably just
at least go fifty I'll just cruise of
the studio and then Porsche pick it up
there nah what's it reduced power that
means shutting down shutting down so
then I had to creep on over all the way
from the left middle of traffic to the
right lane down the side of the highway
safe that's safe
yep so I called Porsche which my car was
in the service with them two weeks ago
Porsche Beverly Hills where I bought my
car in Beverly Hills you know I mean
Eddie Murphy that's where Eddie Murphy
gets his car yes yeah so bring my car in
there I go hey I think something's wrong
my car is smoking the front ones down
the 405 that's not normal they look cool
let's check it out
they have my car for four days pick it
up there we didn't find anything all
good brother
I went nothing that to make sense here's
the video my car smoking my car stop
normal coughing it's got a fever it's
usually the radiators a/c system yeah my
mechanic tell you guys that they sure
you'll be fine
alright turns out not far so in other
words they just let it sit maybe they
tinkered around and it went I will patch
him back up he's fine yeah but it's
normal for a car to smoke you broke my
heart Porsche you broke my heart I got a
call from Brennan said might have a
lemon I might have a [ __ ] mmm you
might and I got a call and you said hey
dude I'm I'm on the 405 right before
Washington Boulevard a neat neat a
pickup sure enough I Drive down there
I'm on my way to the studio
and there you are little lipstick orange
Porsche just sitting there all lonely
all only your huddled up in your car
that's scary by the way because cars are
dude all the way over I'm like if
someone wasn't paying attention I'm yeah
it's clear you get winged it happens all
the time not only that they also say
that there's a condition they this is
fact where people they can't help
themselves when people will be a
standing
on the side of road changing their tire
they're under their car whatever there
are people that can't help themselves
apparently and they they'll just veer
off and clip yeah well those are psychos
yeah that's why they accept but there
are cycles they say it's why you don't
take a nap in your car no I got through
that I get the [ __ ] out there this is
the problem we have the podcast I have
to the Kip shift these things have
rehearsal with E at one in Studio City
can't miss that you got the gold points
you can't say hey golden gloves can you
guys give me a day can you guys
reschedule it because my lemon yeah car
it's 2:16 what car that brahms my love
that's John 18 but question is that I
know it's 2018 Jesus 2016 Jesus Christ
okay
how you been yeah well you've been busy
now can I ask you this well that's like
when my daughter was my heart broke well
my daughter when we we were looking at a
place live and my daughter had been born
and the woman said she has health your
baby and I just weren't I gotta go I
swear to God I go five days old and my
wife went she's she's 15 days old what
she's over toys yeah I was like you just
did sorry
wow I was dead serious too but you
probably sleep deprived it's like when
she said this now she goes how long have
you lived in your place in Calabasas at
a time and I go about eight months she
goes is going on two years what are you
talking about as weird you still pay
attention no idea where my anniversary
is no idea how long I've been there I
don't know details yeah yeah yeah my
heart's broke today guys so can I ask
you this though maybe you know Michael
drives Porsche yeah my brother does
point you at Porsche family you Porsche
family but can I ask you a question you
might even got into fighting gotten
punched in the face and the one while
you were fighting the only thing you
were thinking about was poor she just
wanted to own a Porsche that was your
thing
correct you know I mean that's that's
the dream car now you work you work 16
hours a day you got your dream car you
had to go through all that [ __ ] get
punched in the face all that stuff in
your underwear
now you create a whole life for yourself
in this comedy world podcasting world
they all you're asking for is a little a
little something something for the a
brilliant point A to B you
and you put some money down here's the
thing can I ask you this isn't it true
that with a high-performance vehicle
like a GTS and I don't know what that
means but you can explain it to me that
it's not an everyday car that it's not
to be driven all the time wrong what's
why porch is the best car in the world
really because that cars meant to be
driven every day really yeah
they have the highest reliability Wow
yeah Porsches are the only car that I
would like to have like in a way it
ain't for you
it's not for me you know what would you
guess not for me how about that oh
you're such a big man well no what would
I get there's the GTS what is the GTS
comparatively to so I go I'm going
shopping for a car I want some I want
some speed what do you would you don't
you like their tests look I love my
tests I'll never you have anything but
that I love the Porsche say I want that
car whatever that is this is my car okay
I don't want that damn that's too much
perform the GTO GTS is what what does
that mean it's a guy so there so it goes
to career 911 then there's the Qura s
Yap ins the Carrera 4s then there's the
GTS so that's the that's the
high-performance fast fast car that yeah
and then there's the gt3 this is a GT -
this is gt2 RS what the [ __ ] what is
broken well though what's Rogen has a
gt3 that's like a straight race car
that's probably not everyday driver you
could yeah but you're short before I had
this hiccup with Porsche my plan was
after I buy this house is to get a
Porsche gt3 touring and maintained with
tan interior grand Gran Turismo sport
which is what GTS stands for grand
booty's but how can you out can you rap
these guys man I can't wrap them anymore
well broken heart you might give him a
pass because it's just one Porsche but
they got to make it right Hass name
anyone that's problems with the cars
after in Nice new age of power okay it's
dude no you can't do that
they got to give you a new car like
whatever the problem is I don't know
even if they even if it's not lipstick
old lady lipstick orange I love that
color by the way oh boy I started to get
that color I love that color yeah who
knows man what can you do what can you
I want the GTS Carrera and I want the
Carrera Porsche Carrera
not a car no but not the GTS well that's
a career there's different so there's
like the Tesla the wizard
yeah so there's Wendy Wendy McClendon on
the Goldbergs
she got a new Tesla because she wants to
be in the carpool lane she got the
hundred Dee I'm like Wendy like let me
have that car you drive my 70 I'll Drive
the hundred don't you can't just buy the
hundred if that's like some nights and
cultures though yeah it's ludicrous
package it's so fast it's like to see ya
have a little something for the kid
there's not bad by the way how much are
those 67 grand the that's the king small
one that's the Cayman what is the count
they're smaller okay it's not so you
can't get that why because it's there's
small commoner I'm a big guy my
shoulders and stuff there's I mean my
brother loves them but yeah
I don't know man it's a [ __ ] bummer
beautiful cars they've done a test drive
one uh yeah maybe yeah maybe Ken you
know Jerry Seinfeld's like mr. Porsche
right I didn't know he was like 50
Porsches he does he's missed he only has
Porsches really mr. Porsche Wow yeah I
mean he has other cars but he's missed
like he has a podcast it's just about
Porsches what yeah fanatics oh my god
with Porsche and then when like a new
Porsche comes out he's usually the first
to get it really yeah like the 918
Spyder one GT two cherries got some cash
yeah he's not hurting no this dealer
dude with Netflix there's no Punk no and
you know they're bringing comedians in
cars getting coffee to Netflix oh my
favorite Joe really you know that I've
never watched it I have to go on keep
meaning to what so it's so so good yeah
really old how about the old-school
Porsches that's gotta be that's got to
be a nightmare you gotta have a mechanic
in the back seats well those are
collectors you don't drive that every
day okay
that's the speedster one knows the cars
that would decapitate you when you get
an accident a lot of a lot of heads lost
a lot of heads lost in those cars law
due to guidance of Porsches yeah like
James teams prior times teamed up drove
a Porsche his head rocks what's uh I
thought James Dean count on fire I don't
know but for the story and then the Paul
Walker jr. died in a Porsche ah
I could I heard so many good things
about him yeah me too I'm James Dean
handsome fella was he 27 224 think he
was decapitated guys a Porsche driver
hit a Ford to his name he nicknamed the
dog his car little bastard I had a red
Prius that I called the red Ram those
the worst car every when I first met you
had that Barcelona red as a bummer I
used to park it illegally everywhere it
didn't matter to me I was crazy like
that you just you just get it off the
road man I don't think you've said mmm
[Music]
Wow you know what they said about Rocky
Marciano when he died in a plane crash I
always thought this was kind of romantic
and the writer who's a sports writer of
such a huge fan of Rocky Marciano and he
said they found his body and he'd been
the flame crash and the guy goes all he
would had to do all the guy would it had
to do is just start giving him give him
the tenth the eight count how'd he get
up yeah it's kind of like cool tough guy
but you died how long ago was that
I don't know when Mark Rocky Marciano
died Luke taught up Jim yeah Rocky
Marciano you look that up you guys
wanted to see the house scene right dude
look at that car James D that's
fashionable and drive right poor guy
yeah there's body is that his body right
there
oh that was that's his head that's
photoshopped as a [ __ ] do you
think so yeah man they make sense I
don't know all right Rocky Marciano was
he just an I'm sure if he got his
Wikipedia it's gonna go to death
no I'm phrase relentless fighting style
formidable punching power is the nose
like you bread yep keep going down
trying to say death for God's sake it's
there dude
where there you go right on there oh he
got on his 46th birthday
small probably my pain Oh in 1969 yeah
it was nighttime and bad weather had set
in the pilot Glen had 231 hours 12
flying time okay don't care
35 of them at night he tried to land the
plane in a small airfield outside Iowa
but the aircraft hit a tree two miles
the runway flying marciana in the
backseat was 20 his oldest son former
boxer I'd known my show since childhood
they're all killed on the impact damn
wife died of lung cancer
five years later Wow true like my
grandparents they would never go to a
doctor like never they'd be like I got a
problem that it was like it your body
was treated like an old car and then
finally something would go wrong they'd
be like listen you have cancer got plane
crash is a scary way to go ya know this
year was the latter 10 17 was the safest
year to fly really yeah - amount of
wrecks and my father used to fly a
private plane he was a pilot and he
would take me out and he got out he
bought a jet prop and he had one time
when John F Kennedy jr. died what
happened was apparently they got up to
be about 4,000 feet and I guess they
lost power or something but they plummet
I was like a 4,000 feet okay and he took
me up to 4,000 feet over the ocean we
were in LA and he goes this is the
altitude that they started spiraling
down
god damn I was up there I looked down
and I was like that's a wile it takes a
while oh yeah you're conscious of what's
going it scared the [ __ ] out of me
parachuting III jumped out of a plane
with a slackline and I almost hit like I
almost died - para hike back because I
missed my mark by a mile because I
wasn't listening to the guy because I
was so nervous I was pulling down on
that you glide you know yeah you gotta
do this I'm like noon like that he goes
you gotta let go anyway long story short
but I remember looking down and all
that's holding you as a harness with a
[ __ ] parachute and you're looking
down at what looks like plots of land
that harm is pretty much it [ __ ] yes man
yeah it's it yeah but I didn't like it
does that stuff never make sense to me
Pro a girl we're oh you have a good time
come on you're done well a girl were
with spy starts spinning and she broke
her pelvis and broke her pelvis that's
how bad it was we were like oh that this
is really dangerous you didn't never
make sense them now no thanks
I don't believe you did that any
something's always like hey little [ __ ]
get yeah you just jump up jump you to
get a jump with me
like I'm not doing Annie your [ __ ]
SEAL Team six guys I do that never have
I'm not doing it I'm afraid and I'm
afraid you might like be like you know
what time for us to die yeah I'm taking
a Hollywood actor with me I just have no
desire to do that stuff nobody would
care if I died besides my mom I have no
desire to do that stuff jump out a plane
I don't either I don't either and that
when you have kids like in
rollercoasters now how about happen
how about hot-air balloon I'm an Apple
wife though my kids were born I'm like
they like you should do the airplane and
I'm like me and my wife getting in
somebody else has to raise my kids they
won't be as nice I'm not gonna do it
because we could both die in a balloon
hot-air balloon accident but I also want
Saudi air balloons there's weird to
think about cuz you're Basie and like oh
yeah you're like a wood casket that's
right sir like a bat in a basket sure
they could hold fruit that's right and
sometimes sometimes for whatever reason
maybe it's just a shitload of geese with
a sharp beak I don't know what happens
but you just that that big old balloon
goes boof and you go yeah don't want to
die in a basket how many people die from
air balloons a year though million oh
what no one I don't know yeah people s
they run into something but like
powerful yes oh my god seventy involving
fatalities sixteen people die or not
well ha only 16 is not a lot but you
know again not a lot of people do it
yeah that's the thing how many how many
times six out of how many of its 16 out
of 100 [ __ ] you 16 percent I'm not doing
that well my friend told me about seeing
a skydiver hit the ground when it didn't
open and they were there and he said it
just yet yeah he hit and bounced I guess
though I would think usually you hit and
splatter cuz you're you know you're a
balloon but I guess he hit and bounced
but you're dead as soon as you know yeah
you're not really gonna that's not
something that you survive that's the
scary thing if they catch on fire I have
a problem with that are you serious
that's a virtual and they're pictures of
actual but see that's the one the first
one on that page Oh chin you bring up
these guys were holding
to an air balloon and it took off and
some didn't let go of the of the rope
have you seen that video does he die
well go ahead and see if you can find
this they're holding on like in the 50s
they're holding on to an air balloon and
some of them just don't let go as it
starts to take off I can't strive to
Island them then now you got a hold on
balloon
it's just a giant helium balloon and
what they're in their home on it like a
kite yeah and then it just takes off it
just takes off and you know you go
gloves to later let go let go yeah but
it's - I doubt it now you're [ __ ]
nothing onto it yes it scared the [ __ ]
out of this is it right here
I don't know no no this is this is
people on the ground lifted it this
hippie um no this is a different one
this makes me nervous but see you can
climb into the basket there yeah it's
not it was no basket ass inside no no a
long time ago oh [ __ ] nobody's there
it's there you'll find it you'll find it
it's a hot air balloon yeah it's a it's
a helium balloon just put helium balloon
holding on to helium balloon you know
what
I never forgotten I don't know that
would be brutal it would be the root oh
I don't know dear life man uses a party
balloons at Flo 15 miles some people are
out of there man strapped on a hundred
helium balloons flies 8,000 feet up it
what are you doing I don't know man oh
oh dude he's crazy
oh he's done like a little thing okay
but what do you how do you get down you
just keep popping the balloons with a
pellet gun
15 miles it seems a piece across Africa
oh yeah now you lay on you have no
problem if you landing in a river yo if
you yeah if you land now it's all lies
if you land or a river you got got
plenty of those lines the Oakland A's
it's crocodile
gotta worry about not lines for me bro
you know lines are nothing to me I laugh
at lions I'm gonna give a [ __ ] about one
he's just chillin some people are so
ballsy you have no desire to do that
[ __ ] like the guys who'd climb on
skyscrapers and like Logan has again his
podcast this way does he like climbs and
I met that guy [ __ ] ya nuts I met that
guy as he was leaving Rogen's or he was
going too slow I'm yeah I we had done a
podcast and this guy was showing up and
it was like just kind of at all sort of
athletic looking guy but a regular guy
and does crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah it scares
me
I don't think we're gonna find the
balloon stuff kid I'll find it no I'll
get it I'll get to you we look forward
to that yeah yeah I know you don't
because it's so scary to me this is the
guide I ain't done I think a lot of
people died I think they died in this
video yes they didn't let go and then
they got up to like a hundred feet and
then they let go cuz they couldn't hold
on cuz you know ladies and people don't
climb a rope oh it's in the 15 yeah it's
a video than 50 yes maybe even earlier a
Danby well it's scary you don't see it
no you can see it is it black and white
yeah it's black and white I don't know B
yeah it's horrible be sorry shitty way
to go it would be so I don't want to go
that way
now that let's prefer shirt do you
though yeah oh you don't see you know
it's funny how quickly like if you look
at crocodiles dog gets eaten by
crocodile watch how fast is it wouldn't
be that bad because the dog is like oh
oh and it's barking at the alligators I
mean at the at the hippos and the
photographer's like Oh God
God and you can see the cross just go oh
hey you just last round they just
quietly come around the bank and they
can see it bring it up you see the the
two dogs one gets it yeah yeah I don't
see no one yeah and here's that I know
but humans are different if you get you
by the head if what you're crocodile you
by the arm you're not gonna die for
bringing it around remember that's just
small Brian so they'd fit all the way
into L years mouth that's right sure nah
no so it's gonna take a while
I mean I had the fans can see this right
I'll show a little bit's little bits of
pieces and she's like talking about she
went there to photograph them and she's
also Ryder dogs no she no she didn't
know whose dog here this lady might top
to gamers are nothing new iPhone her on
assignment for ec Mangalitsa wetland
park when I was looking through the long
lens when all of a sudden I saw this
commotion happening in the water there
was some kind of animal running in and
out of the water to maintain the hippos
and soon I realized that it was a
domestic dog when I'm through the crisis
I started to realize that something is
gonna go wrong this isn't a natural
experience this isn't a natural
situation for them to be in the domestic
dog shouldn't be there and there is a
German Shepherd
he's hippos it's a big-ass dog it's
coming could see the tonight four or
five of them getting involved and that's
when I just stepped back from the camera
and decided I don't even want to see
this I knew that something drastic was
gonna happen something really shoot that
[ __ ] this would be such a bummer look at
the Crocs just sitting there like bummer
kind of awesome cuz nature what are the
dogs oh my that's like a regular dog
yeah there see Ellen was gone tragically
that's that quick over Crocs head and
you you stepped on the dot boy oh my god
we get the other dogs like oh [ __ ]
yeah things that shocked me most about
it was how quickly the dog had
disappeared you know in the video the
dogs like what it's over
you see gotta mine the nectar and the
dog went so quick but if it's your dog
it's a bummer but we'll see you later
you know you just you see you can't use
the collar up yeah you can't do that and
they'll digest that collar cuz they can
digest a male hey that other dogs like
and that that croc is like I got as the
other dog trying to go in there help him
no you just got eaten where the hell is
the owner of this thing
damn the oh [ __ ] the video because I
didn't want this dog's life to have been
lost for nothing
oh come on oh yeah yeah that's why you
posted it to understand the risks that
are involved with you because before
that I thought it was okay to go into
the one yeah yeah yeah now you post that
I saw a dog it ah do you know Africa I'm
good I have an Africa twice and I held
up three fingers cuz I was thinking that
I've been that's why I've been there
twice and I've been and I have been on
the banks in Tanzania and Kenya and I
have eaten at restaurants where they
have sized getaway and you're there and
you're eating you're looking at the at
the river and they're just giant rocks
you just check out the oh Christ deals
in Costa Rica we went to yeah if those
are American crocodiles so they tend to
be a little bit more shy however I get
that good whatever I wanted to meal that
happen a drunk I from Guatemala got in
the old water he's drunk gun to that
bridge when they all hang out with a
15-footer so in in ears yeah he got in
the water and they were like what now
hold on you can't just swim around there
i Hong Kong no like cool Crocs of chill
with no no no I also like they're like
well in the river that's the riverbed
that's it's 1500 meters a mile I'm not
swimming in the what that and then they
showed me a 23 that was sunning itself
on the beach where my kids were swimming
no there's a few places I won't get in
any bodies of water including chlorine
pools in hot tubs Florida Costa Rica
Africa that's fair all fair Africa I
don't care now there's no crocodiles
here is that what you're saying have you
ever seen one
yeah if there's ever been one anywhere
near here and get water it's like these
people in Australia the guy goes look
that we've seen crocodiles here they're
like yeah that's quote they jump in the
water the guy who's from there goes I
wouldn't swim here they have been
crocodiles sightings now we're gonna get
in to girls we're getting in did you
need to do - yeah and she said she just
the look on her friend's face as she was
being dragged away from her as a giant
salty wet guy who talked about the
dinosaur yeah a saltwater dynasty
I'm not a dragon I'm talking about here
be dragons a dinosaur right it's a
dinosaur 100% with a reptilian brain
went jack and she goes her look on her
face as she was being dragged away from
me and then underwater and then she's
all maybes not a good idea let me jump
back on the water yeah [ __ ] yeah she got
it deserves it though right hate to be
shitty about it don't get this ogre same
in each I'm not what if you want but
there's [ __ ] sharks everywhere I'm
like nah that'll never happen to me you
kind of deserve it and so sometimes
though like with okay there's a raft
you're in Queensland all your friends
are swimming in the ocean there's about
sharks tend to be you know they're not
gonna [ __ ] ya rabb size to swim from the
raft back to shore and they're all I
said she's a she's you know her
husband's Wyeth and she just disappears
yeah again a great white when I'm gonna
swallow you whole
gives you're a five-foot to woman and
swallow you whole not leaving the
sneakers not leaving top your head and
swallow your whole take you know thanks
for the memories right on sneakers but
yeah you just disappear yeah shark goes
see ya it's like this girl I was dating
I was kind of having sex with she's in
South Africa and she calls me a crying
girl what's up this is 1996 use I have
to go back to South Africa my
brother-in-law was eaten by a shark fun
of his run of at the beach in front of
her my sister and it was actually her
fiance she really loved him and he just
she goes they didn't find anything he
just died like the shark went shoomp and
ate him instead of like biting him in
half like you takes your leg this shark
went so great why did she do it just
bluffing golf them there was just blood
the man she loved you like yeah yeah and
she was probably he was probably 28 and
she was 20 hey Dan Sandler huh yeah soon
over
hey Dan my legs a date tonight
that's the way to go right that's the
way to go it is better than cancer well
you're gonna make CNN cuz if you get
cancer you don't make CNN right well
also eaten by a shark does their waist
do you die progressively and then there
are ways you know work that's a story we
all know where that's a story to justify
eating by a shark and then tigers you
know in high school like male have your
daddy's like swimming and
we're there what's the last thing you
said what's the last thing you say you
have one sentence guarantee the last
years it's right if I'm standing there
let my kid know I just you just like
[ __ ] man
take care of take care of my girl Jane
and I'll be like I will I will but you
hear like a little lost in my voice hey
but even but even as I'm going if it's
some [ __ ] move if I'm like yeah you
make I won't tell my kid that you like
he was like oh yeah like a man noise
yeah you like dude he was like three
good [ __ ] yeah right home that's what I
want to say yeah bring it you [ __ ] tell
my family and friends I said that got
all you got crock but then reality was
yeah here you poo and all you leave is
two turds that float to the surface I'm
like he got eaten and he pooed and I see
those two turds and that's all that's
left of it and I scooped him up I put
them in a jar full Mountain in a bag and
that's and I give that to your girl and
here's how I go you follow that this is
all except a couple of fear poos and he
loves everything you might have to fear
logs fear luck yeah your your dad
squeezed out a couple poos and that's
all he's left you he went out like a
[ __ ] guys yeah he got Susskind cried he
[ __ ] his pants group them out some get
eaten whole keep these information
please save my Gucci shoes yep those are
last Luigi shoes and two turds at least
returning yelled [ __ ] Porsche that's
good
but Borgia those are his dying words
yeah you do poo before you die sometimes
I think animals do when they get eaten
so I demands to to you you have to you
pull your you empty your bowels if you
can smashed by an animal than I get it
but people really poo yes I think it
just depends I mean I've been there a
lot I haven't taken thing gets better
I haven't checked underwear but it is
true that you you [ __ ] maybe bro signs
your body your body goes into shock and
releases you know urine and that's what
the DEP use that yeah stuff I mean I
don't want to be too disrespectful to
people who've died that wasn't I come
back and hunt it
just you know we have to have respect
but III think all of us are fascinated
with with animals that it's when you go
to the zoo who the [ __ ] cares about the
animals that can't eat you unless
they're elephants who can stomp you to
death and hippopotamuses but yeah we
want to go see the animals that that
would that make you feel like food and
shoes ooh should only be full of those
animals all those other stupid animals
well antelopes are glorified cows
glorified forests cows don't let [ __ ] on
my face man if you can't kill me I would
give us oh look at the reindeer mmm
huh don't care no they don't care that's
you save that [ __ ] for a petting zoo the
kids really don't care either yeah I
want to see killing almost fight yeah me
too bro
yeah hey how about I saw Ron Funches you
know they come yeah I saw him last night
and I've never met him before
and he's taught me and Aliyah in the
green room last night and and he's
talking and I go he's a little
conversation should I go oh [ __ ]
you're from trolls and he goes why I go
you're the movie trolls he goes yeah
how'd you know I went i watch it every
day for the past six months with my son
he's obsessed with trolls he's the tall
troll well he believes he's talking he's
living in the middle of a story I know
you're [ __ ] it you're in trolls bro
yeah he's funny a [ __ ] yeah Ron's funny
as [ __ ] I said tonight did an episode of
the Goldbergs I think and if it's one
thing about he was killed me he's very
funny he's a great he's a talented guy
super talented we should get him on the
podcast we really should meet him on
let's get him on yeah he's in trolls ah
bollocks
yeah he's funny as a [ __ ] he's
doing everything he killed her bean to
jelly on that we did a reading and he
was like when you when you when you kill
a room with a reading you know you're
talented look at that look how much he's
worked great comic to myth yeah I bet
smart smart man yeah we should huh yeah
let's get him up
hey man we should hey man don't grab my
knee like that but your sizes got
leaving it's better you know it'll be
better though see how it works yeah
yeah yeah no man it hit me man it hit me
I'm strictly I'm still my strict plant
paradox diet right now they get rid of
it yeah that book saved my ass nice man
tell me what you see could avenge it
sure let's get some current events in
here
are there any fights coming up B nope at
all right everybody's got a break not
for the last two twenty first one is
Jeff Novitzky he was on Rogen's podcast
was so funny he was how good of a sheet
is yeah so he was talking about how his
description on Alexa Amazon's Alexa
actually has Brendan's nickname for him
the Golden Snitch before you play this
and I think Jeff knows this I'm sure
Rogan told him so I like Jeff Novitzky
this isn't I wasn't doing this I've said
this unrolling before I didn't give him
the name Golden Snitch to be mean or is
he funny like that no I just playing
around I think I think I think Jeff
samay got it yeah yeah and if you listen
to his podcast with Rogan I think you'll
like him even more what he's doing for
the sport he's great yeah I love Jeff
well this is a clip that Rogan posted on
his Instagram with Jeff there we go
[Laughter]
awesome I love that it's cool that he's
cool with it yeah it's great
he said he's ry great when I give that
nickname you know people obviously heard
it on the podcast cities walk around the
office everyone was like sub gold snitch
he's like what the five he's gone on
like Shaab gave you the nickname
Constance
that's fantastic so funny man I like
that guy what he's doing for the sport
and everything it's great he's very
thorough dude this is like one of my
favorite rowing boats go that one of
that lady right there have you seen this
yes I have
she says sex
[Music]
dude that musta [ __ ] the hurts it
dead bro because this video this that's
represented I feel that you just blasted
in the face just when you think you're
sexy and cool that is dangerous man that
is poppin Bob and I'll do that about
what I see that I would never like
anything is gonna explode you've been
around something that could explode like
you don't mean like anything like I
don't know you'll just be like oh did
that propane tank you gotta lie you that
yeah like I don't know man that yeah
yeah you tell me there's a bomb in the
area I'm [ __ ] runnin mmm what a
suggestion
well you got the kung fu guy there who
moves people out of the way that's real
there's your arse on tour no that's we
just don't want to go herd rodents again
they'd be weird what else you get
alright first one is so Dana I was
talking to Kevin I Olli today and he
said that if Kevin mm-hmm he had a
one-on-one interview with them he said
that if Connor doesn't return my March
he'll be stripping over the title that's
fair basically yeah Ferguson versus
khabib would go for the actual title
yeah that's fair but but also it's I
don't think it's a threat to Connor
because you know we talked about this
not a big brown breakdown is Connors not
turning down fights this will people
understand he's not like no I'm not
fighting him I'm not doing this but they
have an offer from a fight Devon came to
agreement on a contract she's not turned
things down so when people know she's
stripping right away we're just being a
hater yeah there's nothing to strip he
fought last year he fought Floyd
Mayweather and the biggest fight of the
century
yeah and there's the biggest fight in
UFC history and boxing right second of
all time but if you count the illegally
streamed it's the most watched fight
ever so that that's being active he's
not inactive yeah you know but don't you
worry if you're his coach that he has
taken so much time off like from the
Octagon from MMA and a fight does that
does that play a factor I think you can
look at it that way or you can say okay
well now use a great
Streicher before and he's constantly
working his trainer and I always were
always worried and also he's gotten
tality wear it he's worth to him yeah
he's oh he's it so for him I think you
know one of the takeaways go well who's
gonna really outbox him the FC now
friends the best hands in the especially
after doing a full training camp to
prepare for Floyd Mayweather yeah and
now he's been focused on MMA so I think
there's some out is there gonna be ring
Russ maybe or or now is the UFC to him
just whatever cuz I just fought in the
biggest fight of all time you can't give
me how you can't give me big in that I'm
cool I'm good my hands are better my
defense is better
I found holes in my box tanned up game
you know yep so I was doing my friend
Abdel sent me this interesting thing on
khabib nerd sorry I mean I'm so used to
abuse tomorrow when people when I see a
hand come at me I'm moving so that's why
I my head is so hard to hit now you know
that you talk about all this box do it
like this y'all no no no I my chin went
down I just I just I just I just shocked
it's cold I'm out some guy and could be
he's such an amazing wrestler well let's
just unpack it for a second his uncle
was 1992 world [ __ ] champion his father
was was awarded this really prestigious
like Russian like coach of the year or
something so you're talking about a
young man who was groomed for excellence
with the top like coaching like from day
one
and you didn't know this I didn't know
that I didn't know that that he you know
he was a world sawa-chan he was a
world's I'm a champion as well but it's
just interesting like where you got a
guy who's been doing that
I don't know when did he start probably
three four he's like wrestling and
grizzly yeah yeah that language is
really interesting
so again if he gets you if he gets
underhook he's so far ahead of the game
there's that's the biggest liability for
me with with with Conor if he touches
you it's gonna be a problem it's with
anybody not with any hotter with Tony
first ins going down to he's going and
he's getting taken down understand right
but yeah he's getting taken down yeah
you fight khabib you will never send
after prepare to be taken down over and
over again that's when the fight starts
round and so that's why you work on you
work on your ground game from behind
from the back oh I don't know if Tony
Ferguson and kabhi that's where the
fight starts it hits the ground because
Tony so good off his back for Conor that
he's gonna have to work on your is
submission games different than Tony so
he's gonna have to work they're gonna
get up standing up and hopefully land
their Daniel shot yeah I ain't hoping to
drag khabib in the later rounds and
wearing him out yeah come out but that
that but also cause one of the most
dangerous men in the world in the first
two minutes of any round
you can't come toward him the way did
you can't come toward Conor the way
khabib did toward Barbosa you get
knocked down you're gonna get knocked
out right yes because you got much much
heavier hit anything
Barbeau six cakes are amazing yes his
hands are good his kicks are walking my
hands world class no his hands are very
good but his kicks are what make him
special and unique yes Conor's hands and
movements what makes them world-class
his movement which could be some issues
for could be okay yeah could be thought
you know out kabhi bas was probably not
gonna finish you on the ground you can
you know you can kind of weather that
storm it's gonna be a nightmare if you
don't you just well cool you ask what
for 25 minutes straight who-who would
you bring in you bring in world champion
Samba bring in Russian hope I bring in
one guy one guy only Ben Askren oh
really
been askin been asked Universe khabib
would be my number one super fight right
now why because because Ben asked is the
greatest American grappler we have Wow
and wouldn't be anyone in the world
really anyone the world for him not to
be at a level to be compared to GSP s
the Matt Hughes of the world that khabib
's the Connors ISM it's a shame man he's
so talented it's lame [ __ ] yeah he got
[ __ ] over yeah it is you know his yet
is dispute with Dana Dana kind of didn't
like him his style which i think is
fascinating but his style just you know
just kept out of the UFC is he over it
he's ever about retired he'd know he was
in
using one yeah one like what yeah what
yeah so he's over there world champion
he had his last fight with Aoki who he
destroyed and then he just retired what
was been asked wins Wrestling pedigree
because he who's Olympian he was I think
is Missouri I think is that right
Chandler could I think finger that
Missouri I hope I'm not I see him all
the time
Missouri I always see bass cruiser
correct and Arizona State and so he was
a puppy isn't that isn't that a
different kind of wrestling that's
freestyle right it's not Greco it's not
[ __ ] yeah but no he's you got a seed
been African yeah I'm telling you LC
been ask you it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter doesn't matter cuz him on
the ground even when you get you on the
ground is a [ __ ] nightmare the
stories I've heard about that guy in the
gym are ridiculous
really so he's a national champion
Division one wrestler Division one
all-american I mean you're talking about
just uh-oh and Abu Dhabi submission
wrestling world champion competitor yeah
so his jiu-jitsu is no joke either
he's just grappling just grappling
that's all yes that's all he wants to do
and has he had international experience
with Greco players of course yeah of
course being on that national level you
know does does I'm sorry when you're a
high level freestyle wrestler and you go
up against Greco guys though do you once
they get under hooks the Greco guys
gonna beat you
a guy like Ben Askren who's well-versed
in that like you especially IRA Merrick
to like you know cuz a lot of guys who
are good at judo need underhooks too
right
and a lot of Samba is a little different
but like a guy like Ichi I'm Erin we
dressed him like Pat Cummins mark muñoz
Chael Sonnen myself either certain
things can avoid that they have to have
to polish they have to have to have to
have and what if we real high-level guys
can avoid it one of them when things
might be under hooks yeah but you beams
a different story he's a little bit of a
different animal try and do that and
then he gets around your waist where
judo's you know true hips yeah a guy
like been asked so you're saying judoka
my dog I like been asking could nullify
it could be really
Wow I think the bed Astrakhan beat
Skippy would love to see that I think
you're never gonna see isn't ask when
170 though he was 170 but khabib well
sure he is yes they're pretty similar I
usually do it yeah yes
taller but you'll never see it the only
time you see might might be in a
freestyle like if he doesn't could see
it maybe maybe in one of Chael Sonnen ZL
was I think Olympic alternate greco guy
yeah that gels a monster monster but
yeah for better ask him to never kind of
get his DUIs did you ever wrestle a
wrestler on the level of a train with a
wrestler on a level of khabib like a
Samba buyer never saw humble you don't
get a lot of stumble get no no no cuz
it's mostly the leg locks no I mean with
[ __ ] you know and like obviously
phaidor made it big but you know there's
throws it's spacing makes martial arts
but you have to get the submission in
transition like when you own the granite
stop oh it does yeah oh I didn't know
that I did not know that there's
different rules so there's the Freestyle
this combat [ __ ] so give me tough food
so [ __ ] allows various types of leg
locks while now on choke holds focus on
throwing groundwork submissions with
very few restrictions on gripping and
holds down all the rules with Samba but
to get great for MMA that's probably
nothing better uh yeah I can be such a
monster and phaidor - yeah get those
guys based beasts but ya been askin
could be would be they would be the
thing what else you got you speaking of
could be his little brother is gonna be
in the UFC in February and he's also
decorated - he's undefeated - he has one
loss but it's through through a cut
technical they have been murdered ops
are pretty sad about that which one is
he this guy [ __ ] - Jesus Christ
yeah he's having tough customers he's
been brought up I also saw that Kevin I
only think that
Amanda Nunez cyborgs next really so did
you see that I saw this vegan as Meighan
Anderson saying that thing that cyber
posted was fake news
yeah that's fat that's a that's a very
photoshopped picture well that Sabra
posted this yesterday that yes she had a
call and they're we're gonna actually a
set accepted a fight with that no side
not yes no psilocybe or you know her you
know her man helps her with her social
media just it's not smart moves what
they're doing man
why because if the fights unofficial the
in you the numeron umber one rule in the
UFC in arrow Hani learned this the hard
way
don't don't release news before the UFC
you're gonna piss off certain people in
here this it has a fire that's number
one your man drug goes don't say [ __ ] to
we get confirmation yeah because
sometimes when you do that they gank the
fight you don't get the fight but this
is so far from being done
yeah but what isn't what Dana said is
Amanda Nunez is next yeah isn't that
that money from Dana that's what I want
to see from Dana White's you know now
for you obviously you know he talks a
lot of hype stuff like that but usually
say that's next
I mean wow that's an amazing fight
hell yeah right but it that kid that
Kevin oh I only interview just drop some
jams huh it was it just came out it's a
long one she was like 35 minutes long so
there are some gems in there yeah most
likely
yeah cyborgs were some Nunez is amazing
that's a super fight I don't assume they
do that in Brazil they were have to
right they don't have to they said big I
mean that be aware
they'd saw the most tickets on assuming
no I mean that that's that they're gonna
sell out if they do in Vegas or Brazil
miss Anderson to me is easy on the eyes
yes yeah pretty pretty big girl too but
about six feet no no definitely not six
foot tall bro I never met her she looks
very tall to me there you go Dana
Whiteside work Nunez his next virgin
burger man uh-oh I think that's in the
same interview then yeah like
before McGregor that means that it it
has to be Connors contract what's going
on there whoa why USC's Jeff Novitzky
doesn't believe John John's
intentionally used steroids
yeah even seen that is that one could
events no but it we heard on Grogan's
podcast yesterday I didn't either
okay I did so you assume everyone's
listen rose podcast but what happened is
is Jeff Novitzky basically said John
didn't intentionally do this oh yeah
which is huge huge huge that's very good
news
yeah so he didn't say yeah one time he
said he didn't intentionally use
steroids no he said he didn't say that
Jay did he didn't intentionally he
actually said he didn't intentionally
use steroids yes no he didn't
what'd he say he doesn't believe the
starting perfect oh that's that's
totally different that's that's jumping
way to forest wolf Jeff Novitzky first
of all turd if Jeff Novitzky even hints
at that he probably has some pretty he
goes everything we put a second term
offense when the first time offense was
found that the person didn't cheat
intentionally just operated with
careless disregard okay so so the first
time they believed he was rather
reckless he's saying for the second time
- uh-huh
okay would send some pot so no if he
says that so this is no way it's kind of
the first time he's been caught if he
used intentionally which should be a
one-year suspension right so so positive
and competition for the tested steroid
oral terminal following his third-round
knockout of Daniel Cormier and so here
be this is boring as [ __ ] so what's
going on is the the Jesus so here's the
thing what he took they're saying a guy
who would cheat with steroids would it
take that so you see and that's the
first red flags like if you're gonna
cheat cause you know you're gonna get
caught yeah and he was even the students
first in the world if you're gonna do it
you wouldn't do it like this okay and
then they found it in some other stuff
but what he's and this is my thing so
you're gonna take this guy's word for
what it is Tim because when he brings us
up he has legal actions to be taken
against him so he mentioned something
like this it's just not alike
Oh
maybe that's fine but you can't say he
said he didn't intentionally take it
because that's way overboard
so what Joe did it was so what would you
say Chen he says yeah it's most likely
that he didn't do it but he didn't say
he didn't do it right
but he's nude no I believe they said
that he didn't intentionally take
steroids he got careless he took
something that and by the way it's the
kind of story that if you were trying to
get away whether you would never take an
oral turban off you wouldn't do that
would take terminal at all but here's
why this is a torment because yeah so
all right so this is why this is
important because if you didn't
intentionally take it his suspensions me
Whaley yes which please make that happen
I want him back yeah like that did
that's huge chit hear him even
mentioning that is so good he has said
it's so big but does he have the power
what is his influence on the Commission
that's seen of its he says that's why
the UFC's you saw the programs different
than others because they don't have the
power okay because they can't go oh well
he's a huge superstar we need him let's
give him less suspension there's the
this other party has no vested interest
in what happened BFC right but they do
if it was reckless behavior and he was
it intention to cheat during a lower
[ __ ] I know that cowboy Cerrone calls
Jeff and goes Jeff I'm in Mexico and I
want to take an Advil and Jeff goes
don't hold on don't take any risk I got
something for you over here like like
like you should be caught in I don't
know if you got his number but you know
if you're John Jones I would be calling
him with every question hey there's this
there's this [ __ ] drink that I want
to drink so let's let's go into this
again so another thing he talked about
was supplements he even brought it up
himself he goes a lot of people say that
sometimes supplements will have
something in it and people will know
that that the supplement has it but
that's their that's their scapegoat
right
so they'll purposely take that
supplement but public perception allows
them to go like well I didn't know it
was in there yeah that's my bad no he
just said that we look into that and in
a real detailed way but he never said
like what he meant by it he didn't know
he he said he said what
happens if so if you have a supplement
right people go well guys are taking
stuff and they say oh I took this
supplement I didn't know he was well if
you're gonna go that route and they go
people that's you know people are like
that's a cheap way to get out of he goes
no no it's not that it doesn't work like
that
they actually have investigators police
detectives that look into that where if
they go oh we took the supplement thing
okay to get someone they take that
product then they find out where that
shipment came from and they buy their
own stuff then they investigate that to
make sure all that stuff but that's
proven my point look if I know that a
supplement has some [ __ ] in there right
yeah that's gonna have like let's say
that this creatine has steroids I know
it yeah
but cuz you know you know this industry
everyone has friends that know things
and there's forums you find out right
say I know that it's in there then I
know it's in there then I'm taking that
knowing that it's in there but knowing
that you know public perception sells
like oh he didn't know but I knew ahead
of time that it was in there and that's
why I took it
do you know I'm saying yeah kind of but
doggone Jonas it gives me a gives you a
little leeway and I think really Jim
because when John Jones to true the
Trumbull owner or the [ __ ] scrub all
that's not gonna give you that much of
an advantage you know you can be tested
but dude come on man these people are
not that stupid especially John that I
caught this many times pretty stupid
well okay he's he's not sure if I was
gonna judge stupid he's intelligent
human being he's reckless cheat I'll be
reckless by taking a supplement that I
knew had something and turbulence again
he might have been taking creatine him
I've been taking something that he
thought was for sure not tainted we all
do that right we'll make like when I
take a supplement I assume it's what is
set on the bottle if it's a reputable
company that's fine but a lot of people
don't a lot of people figure out what
stuff is in certain bottles here's
another risk though there's forms and
everything else that say that yeah
here's the thing I don't think it was it
could have been you know they could have
chopped it up with cocaine it could have
been some accrete argument it doesn't
make any sense
by the way that makes a lot of sense so
if you're doing blow they chopped it up
with Harper Santino that creatine could
have this crumble only I seriously
seriously doubt that but he does coke
although he likes his coke so hold on
what do you think Capuchin you think you
think John
taking massive amounts of steroid that's
like incest in the holdup past two of
them and then tested hot for one with a
[ __ ] Easter electron blown you think
that's why he's so good no I think
people that are reckless will do that
kind of [ __ ] I do I think I think
someone that'll sabotage himself because
I won't wait I don't think that's still
a way a way out of being a best fighter
of all time well you're saying is that
there could be self sabotaging behavior
here III see that and I think that's a
legit thing but I don't think it would
be this way I think it's more likely
that he was doing like either blow that
was popular so then or whatever that's
gonna make sense if that's the case then
while as long as the law allows why
don't they have the people that got the
blow test that blow that he was oh yeah
let's just talk about that so hey drug
dealers that gave me a legal honor you
want to go there yeah if you wanna if
you want to blame if you want to blame
if you're gonna go that let's go test
all the coke what I'm saying is that he
could have done he could have taken
something yeah I'm gonna buy Jeff
Novitzky thing because Jeff no means he
said a couple things one is if you were
trying to get away with taking steroids
wouldn't last one you would take would
be Turner ball because it's so easy to
test that that would then say you took
something now was it an athletic
performance drink probably not but we do
know one thing
he shoots [ __ ] up his nose we also know
that when you're in a bathroom with a
chick or whatever you're doing in that
situation or at a club you definitely
don't have a testing kit what you're
doing is somebody says this is good blow
and you do it now also cocaine are
exactly the most clean shake holy I've
already looked into it they caught it
with so much [ __ ] no I don't have to
look everyone knows that you could you
cut it with a lot of stuff so if John Jr
judgment was let's say he's on some
serious peds like actors like some Brock
Lesnar [ __ ]
you're not gonna test positive for this
[ __ ] yeah ok so let's go back to the
cocaine Wow when was the cocaine tested
I mean what was this test taken and if
you would have taken cocaine at the same
time well he if you getting caught would
he have gotten Carla he know he does
cocaine right up well he's waiting quite
nice yeah no I'm saying like you know
there's in competition a competition
whatever that is yeah during the time he
got caught for this trainer ball would
that be a time you could take cocaine
and get away we don't know but
these these these tests that they're
using are pretty sophisticated and very
sensitive we know that like China is
using so we're just putting it down
right now you guys believe that it's the
cocaine I believe it was a tan to
supplement that he knew he was taking I
don't know what it was
but I don't like I don't think I don't
think he was a tainted Kaplan and I
think he was doing some sort of drug
cocaine or something like that partying
I don't think he intentionally cheated
me I don't so the last thing about the
Nowitzki thing is when he said that you
know we we take it to the labs and all
stuff what does that mean with if you
already know you're taking a supplement
that has stuff in there like you found
out through your friends through the
underground whatever you found that this
stuff in there so okay they test it they
found out that is in there oh one men
what do you mean why is that why does
that help if Jeff Novitzky says beep
this so let's say let's say we're all
UFC fighters here and you're taking some
PD and you blame it on this supplement
you're gonna get a lower suspension I
didn't know oh it's [ __ ] here that's
crazy well they can test it and see if
it's it because sometimes you can taint
your own supplements I can mix [ __ ] in
suppling I know I know how part I'm
saying Nowitzki saying like we know
those guys can't get away with saying oh
I thought it was just in the supplement
yeah guys you'll get suspended but the
guys that know it know it's in there it
makes no difference so saying that
Whoopie here's the thing chin if you're
taking legit peds and you just blame it
on that that's not gonna work anymore
also if you're taking us like let's say
you're taking a scoop that has some
trauma but alone or where the [ __ ] is
calling it it's really not gonna help
you that much it really doesn't make
that much sense to do it yeah just cuz
it doesn't make that much sense to do it
who knows what this guy's been doing
this entire time I know he's reckless
I'm charlie
we know yeah who knows if he's been
doing this kind of stuff I would I would
guess that because of his history of
drug use I I think it makes a lot of
sense there was something cut in that
cocaine yeah if you're gonna cheat now
see that the greatest of all times like
gonna cheat with that we'll say that
then you guys believe that and I believe
this you believe he's not peds
I believe he knows enough people to
where he would get supplements that have
certain things in that little boost by
you sod that might not everyone knows
you get caught though yeah but you the
same thing with cocaine though no no
cocaine turn it out like this like this
yeah and if you test for cocaine now
cocaine of competition you know I can
suspend it really it's not that big of a
deal hmm
either way I'm very encouraged that we
might see him back in the Octagon yeah
well he you should especially if it's
something like this yeah I'm back on the
John drain good because he is a beast
chins against Joe and I want to see why
some people do that stuff I want to see
him fight the big blonde Gustafson no
why what do you mean what's that about
some fight huh
some fight I'd like to seem good a
heavyweight Tom Wow
that's a good point but we saw the best
we just had surgeries been out for a
while um you'd like to see him fight
Kane steepen yeah he's got a heavyweight
I don't know what the thing that 4dc
like that's tricky like what do you see
[ __ ] John DC again no no no you will
never beat him just not in the cards
like seemed gonna every weight yeah I
guess in gone alright alright let's move
on yeah Francis
John John's gonna be sick oh Jesus
there's so many big fight for John if
you can beat this case I hope you beat
them on let's go
they'll be Oh Jason let's go alright
Tyson Fury yes went on his Twitter and
called out Anthony Joshua he's been he
said that would be his first fight back
after two and a half years he doesn't
want a warm-up fight you see Chris
calling him out that's badass I hope it
happens but I mean Joshua's fighting
Parker and then he'll fight wild or so
fury meme by the end of the year Fury's
gonna fight someone before Josh Bell for
sure what he's crazy enough to do that
but what do you think
think about what I just told you well
I'm saying if Tyson and Josh we have ice
what you're feeling
Oh a better fighter like Aizen
technically better boxer they're both
phenomenal phenomenal fighters at that
level they're both very good um if fury
has is my right he's in shape I mean
he's gonna be anyone in the world on
depend on the night
that's a tough fight for Joshua super
tough fight Fury's awkward as [ __ ] he's
huge get footwork am I am I wrong to say
that 2018 the fight game is strong the
fight the sport of fighting is strong
like there are so many great fights in
boxing and MMA men and women and I have
a philosophy I have a theory on why this
is I believe that as men become less and
less able to express their true nature
in society because there's this idea of
toxic masculinity and boy on a real
scent though no but still I know that
boy well it's not that reason because
boys in school are told not to
roughhouse there's not a lot of
expression for young boys I'm living
this right now my son they're there
they're constantly having to keep their
their sort of natural nature down I
think you're over shaking a little I
think I think you're gonna see somehow
that that need to express that
aggression find its way who fighting yes
now I disagree especially where you're
it's more it's more wouldn't be where
I'm I'm from well well I'm not saying
where we're from
yeah we're in Santa Monica there's the
white biscuit you know I said this the
privileged kids they're not gonna
gravitate towards fine
no but they be so aggressive they're the
boys I'm saying her yeah but they're not
professional fighters cuz they're
suppressed in classroom yeah but you see
a lot of kids doing jujitsu you see a
lot of kids at boxing burn you see a lot
of this like I I don't know am I am I am
i all off you're off on this so
Fighting's not more popular now than it
was say 10 years ago 20 years ago the
UFC ratings would prove you wrong okay
and what about this is their worst year
ever really yes so what about fighting
as a career fighting as something that
people do more of like recreational so
more jiu-jitsu schools more blogs just
talking about the evolution
of the business of mixed martial arts so
Jitsu you know and so I'm saying as a
sport is fighting more popular now or or
less popular than ten years ago
in other words like that's silly to say
because the UFC has to deal with Fox
know you mean just all-around yeah not
because your boys are told they can't
roughhouse and no boy I'm saying is
fight maybe in 10 years not from now but
that's kind of a recent thing
well fighting in this country in the 20s
and like 30s and even in the 40s and 50s
like a lot of people boxer boxing clubs
there were fighting clubs that like a
boxing itself was like Rocky Marciano
that everybody would watch those fights
like fighting there wasn't a lot of
entertain right though right but still
fighting then somehow went kind of it
had it had its dark period I've always
had you always had great fights like
Hearns and Duran but for the most part I
feel like the early 2000s I feel like
even the 90s wasn't as popular certainly
wasn't boxing sure but it surely wasn't
as popular say the 20s and 30s there
were renaissance box and fighting
renaissance is in this country at times
nineties were III gotta look into this
as you do you do 90s were huge for
boxing I think you talk about more macho
kind of things when I wonder if fighting
in general is on the rise as far as like
just as a sport among young people
especially young men I know way more
people are training than I've ever met
in my life
for sure cuz it's more available is it
more available as they're more interest
is the avail to what comes first
well there's but there's gotta be more
attention it's gotta be demand as well
for it to be mother of FC's on Fox you
have season forgetting you have seen you
know see what do you mean for you you'll
see there's the reason why Fighting's
legit look at boxing - boxing is going
around for how many years how many
boxers I just feel like boxing right now
is there's so many good fights so I
wonder if there's more demand to learn
fighting from the guy who's the agent at
CAA to the guy who's the actor at 50 to
the kid who's 14 you know I wonder if
this if this sport in general the combat
is more
than than it has been say since the 20s
what do you think yeah it's a ridiculous
question why because it's everywhere now
it's bits more available so that's my
point but it's not manager sons being
suppressed in school it's my point is
it's because hearing there's more
availability anyone can do it now has
more eyeballs it's a major mainstream
sport now yeah but that's why why is it
a major mainstream sport it is a it is
an expression of somebody I I think that
that as you are less able to express
your aggressive side in society in
general okay where the consequences are
[ __ ] huge you get sued or whatever
school is telling you not to roughhouse
I believe is to fight it'll find its way
I don't see simulation I don't think
you're gonna see people sign up party is
but I mean you're just saying as a
stress whether of course people live yes
and well they decided now take fights is
one thing but it's another thing to be
on the mat I don't know how suppress
people I mean I I know you get up from
your side but kids can play football you
know there's a lot of things they can do
and not fly yeah I don't know I don't
have the I don't I haven't of course
Fighting's more popular than ever I mean
you have seized up considered a
mainstream I would say it's it's right
don't things cause of suppression of
children though I don't know IIIi think
it's too early to call that no it's been
going on for a while I've done a lot of
reading on this it's been going on for
twenty years it has not when I was
growing up yeah well in a lot of places
it is I don't know you know especially
communities worrying I don't see those
kids turn into fighting well they are
there are a lot of jujitsu
schools and boxing gyms in Santa Monica
itself you know a lot of kids with kids
in it sure a lot a lot a lot mmm very
popular so Lee Jim Jefferies would beg
to differ
speaking of fighting everyone's been
asking me like crazy and even das Brack
made his poster yes we're no we have to
get the ring but it's have to do it we
have to do it yeah but uh I'm not gonna
get any train
and we're not gonna move around first
we're just gonna go spark I love it I
love it you have that's the only way we
don't the only way that's fair now
because if I get training then people
will say stuff and just come down yeah I
want to present we'll do it whenever you
want I'm there all I'm sure when should
we set up cuz I'm gonna have to be there
to film it for the fan people are coming
up coming through with filming stuff to
you they said they want to do a
countdown we'll have to do one day I'll
set up a box and burn I'll talk to Tony
well just have fun it's nothing serious
yeah uh to try and do in February give
you a little time [ __ ] I mean time for
chin
well Brian works out though you don't
work out it gets tired
oh it's definitely happening 100% in
February yeah all right well it will
pick a date I will figure it out after
this okay we'll make it we'll do a sure
around it we'll do it live on [ __ ]
you too anyway you guys want to do it
all right we'll do it yeah it'd be fun
are you laughing Brian you shouldn't
laugh be interesting it's gonna be fun
what if he beat you up right what if he
knocked you out what would we do
we'll say would you have to retire
that's not so awkward I like swing like
swing on each other but you see me
awesome yeah for changes I'm not moving
around be worth sup set when he kept him
to move around
I wish it would just secretly come down
with me and what I do it now be dropped
asked what's not happening when when you
move around we're gonna film it okay so
you want me just to see cuz you want me
to be prepared for a little bit what
you'd it that's not like like even if
you and I just go down there and just
just you know just you Saul around you
around one more time I'm gonna freak the
[ __ ] out yeah that's not happening
though when you guys meet we're gonna
film it it should be the first time that
we meet that we spar have you ever have
you ever been in a ring no have you ever
have you ever been hit in the face I've
been in fights I told you like but like
have you ever been hit in the face hard
I have a huge scar on my head right so
I've been it's go super super so you've
been in how many fights it's street food
on the
she only where Oh everyone but you have
yeah cuz you have Han I don't know if
it's Han here's that anger I don't have
a anger the fans odds are they're
betting on chinoe I got to be honest
with you that's so trippy because I'm in
the beginning I think it's because
you're sighs okay in the beginning they
were all like on Brian sides and now
they're saying we'll put the pullback
I'll keep at Kay I don't know and then
it's gonna go down it's gonna be funny
okay I hope when you get knocked out of
your dude oh and then uh after we're
done I think it's time that uh you and
me step in there you wanna fight Brendan
no not fight jr. dear mind I will twist
your friend you have no idea just Justin
we'll see now was cute before it was you
Brian I was on board
Jen I will try no [ __ ] I know Brenda
would want to just destroy me no it's no
I would never have a chance I would
never do it yeah it's crazy
Oh God I know I was on board I'm telling
you I know but now you know what hold on
it said scene from Step Brothers at
first I was on board he wants to get in
with a demi for did you know what
now these tuxedos make you guys seem
kind of creepy that's just that say what
I'm gonna let Brendan I'm gonna do this
and then you're gonna fight Brennaman
listen no I'm not going
Brendan's only gonna punch you about the
arms and chest that I would even do then
I'm not gonna hit your body is just
going on I'm not going in there mom
playing around easy because he he's
gonna just use it jack I know bread and
said would they wanted this guy goes
boxes a lot he's good and I said how
would you do he goes I use my left hand
I'll get real with him but I just beat
him with my left hand I honestly I knew
that would piss him off Steve and how a
personal fight of course silly
oh dude it's a whole different thing I
did that for fun that's funny but you
guys should but you just said you want
to get in the ring with it and you would
Oh Jay Jay's friend Jason said if you
were to beat chin Jason wants to fight
you then and revenge chin thanks Jason
you know Jason Jays boy for Payson we've
in New York
Jason by the way I'd be worried about
Judah's a lot of more - [ __ ] you're
worried about Jays Jason
a lot of any piece fan you know any
prepared for dancing you Jason you'd
[ __ ] you late damn right dude I said
when you see a dude like Jason who's
been throwing like I watched him dance
he's heavy
he's got a head he's got that Filipino
bone structure that mark huh damn bro
bro let me tell you something sweater
like [ __ ] God
I guarantee he can hit and kick like a
[ __ ] freight train and I live with my
with my bone structure and he knows what
he's doing he's fought well this is what
he told me yesterday Jason said if you
beat chin he wants revenge I'm not is
really not gonna get in the ring
[ __ ] cuz how much face where
you could really hit him I don't I'm not
getting in with a guy like that where I
could get hit in the head and have a
headache for a month I'm not just I
don't Wow oh it says you're getting in
there you're seeing that right in front
of me to you but genu net you don't do a
lot of boxing so that this is a guy who
actually trained for a fight and he's
thick he's trained easy for a fight
yeah like cutting weight like he can
he's training at a one kick knee throw
the [ __ ] key can [ __ ] hit maybe
you may have seen him hit I can just
feel it he's got those giant calves he's
a big boy but yeah he sweat so much I
don't know I've seen it
his head sweats all the time he sweats
non-stop I'm not interested in I like I
don't like getting in the ring with the
dude like that where you're like where
where you're really gonna try to knock
each other out this is not what I do
well that's what jinda so you know I
would not try to knock him out like I
say it'll be for fun sparring bro but
the first time we move around is the
first time we spark I like your style
what else you got brother are you good
on time I got maybe flat one more real
quick Carrie Underwood so remove that 40
50 stitches and she's not supposed to
look the same anymore so a picture came
out recently of her by a fan and she
looks perfectly fine hmm why can't tell
I'd have to see up close but it should
explode it's pretty close and actually
this girl's from below deck that show on
Bravo
oh man she looks like her face looks a
little bit
I was gonna say that if stored it at
that yeah like a the nose bent it a
little bit little swallow swollen yeah
all right kids one more Oh
jean-claude Van Damme I guess accordi
gar Brown did you see this says when
sparring goes wrong so they sparred
together for they're just jokingly
sparring together and then Van Damme
accidentally kicked him in the head or
the teeth and what's with gar brand do
you'll hear I'm talking about it right
now
to me it looks super light so then the
codis go [ __ ] he wanted to fight
him so Van Damme tried to apologize he
wouldn't accept that hook kick I was
like so mad I look over at Rob I look
look at John as they robbed my teeth
dude kick me in my teeth like playing
around like Cody is not the guy to do
that to men yeah what the [ __ ] John he's
not how fun you have been if you just
murk John Claude Van Damme like this guy
who he's up there a 35-pound he was at
Club works big guy who's 35 and he's
like walks around 165 and he was
sparring with people and and they asked
me if I wanted to get in the ring with
him and I go now I'm okay I'm not gonna
get in the ring with that guy he's
fighting right now and just not gonna do
it and he said to me cuz I guess a guy
got in there and was an amateur and he
[ __ ] hit him and he goes I'll go as
hard as you go but they're due to get in
there with a guy like that who fights
professionally and they up it and they
start really swinging for the fences and
don't forget that the guy's a [ __ ]
fighter if you hit him in the face
something's gonna trigger and he's gonna
come back at you so if you want to play
that game okay yeah you know Greg goes I
was like I'm gonna rip his head off
let's John Claude Van Damme where he's
supposed to Wow Van Dam is crying too he
said it was actually on his knees crying
and he says my champion
Garber and Carver did not react to would
he do you well for sure get up Frank Dux
man that's a bummer hilarious though I
mean it just looks like a hook kick
still you can't kick a man no I just now
I know how to fight Cody but I gotta go
man are you to roll kids all right that
was awkward that's an I feel awkward for
jean-claude now players though it's so
funny Cody Cody is a [ __ ] rattlesnake
he's not the guy to do that that guy's
the hell no you will rip your head off
for reals I'd be where you gonna be men
um I'll be in Nashville January 11 12 13
I will then be at the Columbus funnybone
25 26 27 of January and then I'll be at
the DC Improv February 1 2 & 3 come see
it come have fun let's do this man
Brennan where are you gonna be in
Portland next week Thursday Friday
Saturday when Shawn Thursday night two
shows Friday to show Saturday tickets at
t f-- at kake.com get him now this is
the fire kid we're out